hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar investigation of endothelial
cell viability and growth on 3d printed
Gemma vascular networks presented by
crassula chapel postgraduate student
University of Manchester
and procedural love lab rats and I will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
thermo Fisher comm /stel culture heroes
now let's get started
you may submit questions at any time you
want during the presentation just simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send your questions will be
answered via the contact information you
provided at the time of registration if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation click on the support tab
found at the top right of your
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of your presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I'd now like to introduce today's
speaker crassula Chappell postgraduate
student University of Manchester for a
complete biography on crassula please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen crassula you may now begin
your presentation
so hi everybody and my name is Chris ela
Chappell
I am from the University of Manchester
we're predominantly the biomaterials
group and we're based not at the North
Campus really where the cast off but
we're good people
so I'll be talking to you about the
investigation of endothelial cell
viability and growth or 3d printed gel
mark vascular networks now gel MA in
sports gelatin methacrylate and hydrogel
so my supervisors are Olga suku and
Professor Brian Darby's that are very
well known around those fields so if
we're just going to slide want to give
you a little bit introduction so the
reason why we doing this project is
because of our breast cancer and these
are UK statistics and in the NHS so in
2007 seeing around sixty three thousand
four hundred and women were diagnosed
with invasive breast cancer now evasive
breast cancer means it spread outside
the nodes of the breast now the most
predominant one is DCIS and which is dr.
carcinoma in situ and it's a very common
form and as you can see from the
histology which is got the pink and the
purple stain it's when the breast dogs
of their where the women produce the
milk actually get cluttered with
malignant cells and that's the most
invasive form of breast cancer now women
because when they inherit that disease
and they tend to do breast augmentation
and that involves complete augmentation
they lose their breast completely and
that can hamper you know their
confidence so what surgeons have tried
to do is they have tried to put fat
tissue up there to restore the breast
but because there's no vascularization
obviously the breast tissue died and as
a result a lot of scientists now are
going into the tissue engineering mode
and we're trying to figure out a way to
introduce artificial vascular ization
for these women
so I go to my next slide what makes a
successful 3d tissue development and
does it really need vascularization the
answer it
yes and the artificial vascular networks
are first you know I've printed or
they're casted but we're going to use
the 3d printing method we use a simple
robotic printer and it prints out a
quranic f12 seven and that's a little
bit also offers the fact n't and it's a
sacrificial material now a lot of people
have used veronik as one two seven
because it's easy to be rid of which is
the opposite to you wax or sugar
angelica methacrylate are actual
hydrogel is casted on top and that what
we want to do is we want for endothelial
cells within those hollow channels the
adipose derived stem cells which is
basically fat tissue are basically
encapsulated within the hydrogel and
what you want to do is you want to
create a feeding system for both the
hulex and the adipose and you want them
to co culture together and basically do
what the surgeons do but you want to
create viable vasculature but it's
artificial now as you can see from my
little picture over here these are
artificial channels that we printed here
at manchester and we actually put a
fluorescent dye through now as Russ and
I shown that there's no obstructions and
that there's no air burn any air bubbles
and that our structure has worked he
hasn't collapsed and he also basically
shows that you know that with these we
can actually put cells through our
structure which is good news for us and
the reason why we've done it that the
hexagon is because we want to make it
look more like vascular ization so for
it'll ask me well how do you do these
channel formation well we use in the
robotic filter the robotic printer is
work like a simple file plotter
so it actually prints the running
filament on glass slide and the way we
actually want it to actually be
successful if we want to functionalize
that last slide with ammonia hydrogen
peroxide in a say line now as you can
see from the little diagram that I've
basically created your glass slide is
with the ammonia and the hydrogen
peroxide is cleaned thoroughly of any
kind of residue so it's absolutely
crystal clear and then you put your
silent our top because your silent is
the one that's going to attach to the
gelatin and you basically make sure that
you know when you cast your gelatin top
it's not going to be attached in the
dmem which of the media conditions
ourselves and it's proven to do that so
once you do your glass slide
functionalization we use the robot
printer and robot printer can do a
variety of shape it's got over 92
programs we tend to usually I would say
about 12 programs so far we draw circles
which are a lot of polygons which are so
many things at the moment and what we
have achieved is we have achieved a 300
micron diameter in each Channel and as
you can see we have created those little
channels and on the glass slide and then
pranic obviously has a lower critical
temperature so it has to be printed at 5
degrees also because obviously it
solidifies at room temperature well 17
degrees are what they are above and then
you would cast your gelatin methacrylate
on top really and then what you do well
gelatin the sacrament because you have
added some a cyclic group in is did you
be polymerized to become a proper
hydrogel and we put it in a UV lamp it's
an LED lamp we actually use something
that people use for their nails it's
very very low spec but it does the job
we leave it there for a couple of
seconds while the gel has basically
formed what we do is we prick it at the
end whatever channels are and we drain
the Parana --q after we put it on ice
because obviously with the ice the pure
on it because it's liquid again and you
flush everything with water and you're
left with a hollow structure as shown in
the previous slide so you're gonna say
to me well while you do this the reason
why we're doing this is because we want
the Subic switch have our begin to feel
yourself to go in this slide invade
those channels and create the artificial
vasculature so you're going to say to me
okay well what are your journal project
x then in that case so here's a slide
for these people the general so are
project aim for my project and
predominantly you know as we do in the
work it's basically doing a 3d viable
vascular tissue construct okay and we
encourage for stem cell differentiation
within the gelatin methacrylate then
what we want to do is we want to create
those frida channels please the 300
micron dimension using that simple by a
block there then we want to cast our
hydrogel on top and we want to basically
make sure that the hue VEX
and the adipose derived stem cells can
grow over time and what we want to do is
we want to create a viable kind of
artificial tissue but people that need
it so we're going to say so how is
gelatin perfectly made it's a common
biomaterial I would say a lot of people
have done a lot of studies on it and
it's made by different masters really
but the most important Leopard and a lot
of people are using it's known as the
one pot synthesis now the one pot
synthesis is a very ideal method because
you know it doesn't use large amounts of
meth acrylic and hydride like the
conventional method and it does need
multiple pH adjustments like the
sequential method so what you do is this
I've created a little diagram for you as
you can see and I create the chemical
bonds for you to follow what you do is
you put your buffers look affair with
your gelatin so and then what you do is
you smudge in water and then you stare
it until it becomes crystal clear now
once it becomes crystal clear you start
adding start doing your pH adjustment
first because you want a pH of nine then
you go into doing and by adding meth
acrylic and high and hydride and that's
drop by drop so you can get a full
dispersion and then you leave it for
three hours for the air for the reaction
to occur once that is done you do a
further pH adjustment so that it could
be near to seven and then what you do is
you put it into a little a pocket and
- dialysis tubing and basically what you
want to do is get rid of any excess
messapus anhydride and you leave it for
a week and that's how you get your
really nice pure product now the things
that I haven't included in that diagram
afterwards is that basically you have to
breathe try it and the reason why you
want to bring strays you want to get at
the water out as much as possible
by forming very small crystals in it and
then you get a firm and once you get
this firm
you are either PBS dmem or water and
cook and then depending on the
calculations and the media percentage is
in the fragment percentage you want that
there that's the amount of the decisions
that you are so then you can ask me well
how do you know about the methacrylic
anhydride has attached so that's when
the next
slide comes in and this is free NMR
analysis now this is known as proton NMR
so it's liquid and amount and basically
what you want to see what we did is we
wanted to correspond our graph our
bindings with the grasp and with the
graph on the paper and that that's a
particular very famous payment from
shirahama Intel which actually did and
the one-pot synthesis and there'd be
optimized there quite a bit and what the
most important thing is that you should
actually do this the green box because
the shorter the peak their amines
the less real icing groups and that's
where the actual methyl clear some
hydride attaches and so forth and that's
the most important big so if you've got
a very small bead then it means a lot
and you know you've got a lot of meth
and grillak anhydride there are certain
other things that you could do
potentially to see you know the how much
you have got attachment like the NSBA
face and but in general and you know
people tend to use the NMR method and so
forth
if you want it people have also
discussed really if they want to look at
it further by doing a server hydrolysis
experiments but however that's very time
consuming and also because of the
complications of gelatin and the way
you've deleted from collagen that's very
very hard to predict because it can't be
cleaved at different methods so people
just use the standard enema but then me
and I decided with my group what happens
after you know we photo polymerize it
can we see any additional peak within
more chemical bonds and we can use them
the liquid enema so we decided maybe we
can use the carbon which is a solid
enema unfortunately and because
obviously because it was too wide to the
plane we couldn't really distinguish
certain bonds but we what we could see
was basically was the whole handprint of
the gelatin really and and basically
they want the peaks that are basically
the very after the big peak the ones
that I've got the widest part
they're all the different groups within
gelatin and that said the most important
people do actually use this method I
know Ali assaulted to distinguish
whether he has been you know hydrolyzed
appropriately from collagen and that's
what we got really it eats a fingerprint
of gelatin methacrylate
so although we didn't get a results
within our spirits go we want to say
well how hydrophilic is our gelatin or
how hydrophobic it is so we did some
contact angle studies and it turns out
that Gerasim exact rice is very
hydrophilic it's you know 21.2 so if
you've got a salty but it's less than 15
degrees that's a very hydrophilic
hydrogen which is very good at safety
health cassell loves being in a
hydrophilic environment the wind because
we're printing with qur'anic and
obviously there will be you know maybe
we can't guarantee the whole of the
qur'anic leave and saying well how
hydrophobic is qur'anic and so forth and
it actually is very hydrophobic turn 75
which is certainly to be morgan above
threshold really but no over the Napo we
decided to carry on with ourselves
ourselves to these so we did cell
studies and we did encapsulation this is
a 2d cell culture that we use the
adipose derived themselves first of all
and what we did is we groovy as opposed
to out themselves and with a different
time points day one day four day seven
so within the encapsulation as you can
see this adipose derived stem cells from
day one actually elongate and they
trying to invade the gel but if you do a
2d cell culture on them they actually
form little clusters and i should point
out that we deployed microscopy and then
the warmth next to it otherwise death of
the green stain predominantly carlson
and that shows that the cells are alive
and then the third one is basically when
the cells and we're looking at the
cytoskeleton the acting of the cells and
we're looking at the nuclei as well
so the more organized reactant then the
more likely the cells are very healthy
and they're willing to proliferate on
the job just good news for us from day
one then we go on to day four and as you
can see the cells have actually exploded
within the gel when they're encapsulated
not only can we not found any red dead
cells but the acting is so well
organized in its spread in our product
really encouraging but we've also seen
that phenomenon with our 2d cell golf
champ which proves actually that the
cells were very encapsulated or whether
they're on top they still liked the
environment then you go into day seven
and the cells are still looking happy
they're still proliferating and this you
know with barely any dead cells you
thought there is non rarely and what you
want and these are positive results and
that's what you want to see within your
cell line so basically our Rd posterize
themselves are more than happy to be
encapsulated opt for seven days and we
are assuming that it would be happily
encapsulated even after the seven days
does it go into a next slide we did a
control and basically this control group
is the human dermal fibroblasts my human
dermal fried rice' fun in your skin
they're very easy to grow so they're not
stem cells or a primary cell line but
however we use of our control so for our
encapsulation which is basically around
this box as you can see we did it the
same as the adipose derived stem cells
from day one day four and day seven that
they want again you can see that the
cells are actually trying to spread
within the del the really elongated so
well organized
then don't day one on to D cell cause of
the forming clumps still but we will get
there and as you can see on they fall
they started to form different cells
from the clumps and on top and then
within the encapsulation as well they
started to spread more and by day seven
really they've invaded predominantly
most of the gel and again there's barely
any cell death and you know the acting
is very well organized
just something that we want to see it's
very positive results then we go on to
our human umbilical vein and the serial
cells now the human umbilical vein and
of venial cells we only did a 2d cell
culture studies and the reason for that
is because the human umbilical vein and
deceive yourself I'm not going to be
encapsulated within our gel I don't want
to do that we don't want to create
necessarily about artificial environment
for them because we are sin stem cells
from the name as well we are derived
from the umbilical cord of their babies
now the babies are born and then the
mother or L the parents can donate their
cells freely and what you get really so
we used a port version so all these
cells are actually from different donors
and because he gets a variation really
you don't want to constrict the
genetically to one individual and then
what you can see the human and umbilical
vendor feeling cells are a bit more
sensitive they require up to day 14 for
me expand within the hydrogel and that's
not because there's something wrong with
the hydrogel is because of the way they
grow really so on day one as you can see
they are forming clusters like the other
two cells did and then on day on day one
scuse me and a four as you can see more
self can be visible day seven they're
forming more air colonies and then by
day 14 they've expanded into the hard
shell which is positive and that's what
we want to see eventually when you
actually want to create the artificial
vasculature for them the cubix will
eventually invade that hydrogel and what
we want to see is we are thinking of
potentially adding an artificial pump
and we want to see whether there be any
differences to you know the way they
actually behave
I still have an aesthetic culture really
so if we go further on so have we done
any kind of preliminary studies so I'm
going to compete with that
yes we have printed the channels and
preliminary results have shown that this
we have put
it's in there now we've only done it
birthday quantal - really because it was
so many little tasks that we want to do
and you guys shown that the cells
through attack shock shine and they do
survive but we need to actually
encourage that server now we've noticed
that I do want to elongate as well but
because we only went up to a 48-hour
point it would be interesting to see
what it would be like after 14 days and
however we did notice that even though
you did get attachment on the gelatin
parts of the hydrogel because obviously
they are have got the glass slide
underneath there was hardly any
attachment there so we're thinking maybe
we have some gelatine of the production
or something some cells can grow on that
part as well and the other thing is with
notice is that even if we've got to D or
an encapsulation and experiment within
our cell culture we've noticed Alki cell
viability and that's the most important
thing is that ourself enjoy the
environment and they're not constantly
dying they're happy to divide and
they're not even differentiated at that
point dreaming so we don't know we might
good my fruit I should point out that we
also did more control studies as well
with nanoparticles a visa for Astana
particles as you can see from the
fluorescent image on top and basically
we wanted to make sure by putting
fluorescent nanoparticles there were no
obstructions there were no leaks in our
artificial channels and we proved that
which is positive so I would also like
to conclude what Voyager future worker
would be like I mean you know you've got
a lot of work ahead of you but what do
you actually want to do that the end we
predominantly want to achieve basically
expanding our 3d printing and basically
co-culture in our cubics and our adipose
derived themselves together so by
culturing artifacts and seeing whether
they can survive after 48 hours within
that environment then additionally and
the adipose derived stem cells it be
really interested to see whether we get
any more concise PT 31 or
you need that hearing which was warm in
a wonderful form so also we want to
potentially start introducing and in
vivo by a reactive because then you are
creating an artificial tissue an
artificial environment and you want to
see them proliferating we actually and
I've included some hydrogen
characterization because I want to know
more of our hydrogel and we are
currently doing that first on a lot of
extension and real article analysis and
we send EMA analysis and we found some
interesting results fast but at the
moment we're mostly interested about how
our cells are going to react because
this is the biggest things really and if
we can make this a possibility then you
know we can advance the project further
more than we have both and you know if
you would be incredible and for our work
creaming so I would like to thank you
for listening to me and I would like to
thank professor Bryant be dr. Alva Tico
they think they worked really hard with
me blessings you weren't countless hours
with me to get this far so big thank you
to him the EPSRC and it's our funding
body and for the engineers and I would
like also to thank the people that given
me the opportunity to do this
presentation and please feel free to let
me know if you do have any questions so
any questions please do let me know be
more than happy to answer thank you
thank you Chris Allah for that
informative presentation and as a
reminder we are taking questions and
those questions submitted now and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be answered via email to the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
now I'd like to thank Rasul Allah for
her time today and for her important
research and I would also like to thank
lab Rhodes and our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us and don't forget to check your inbox
if you did submit any questions
webcast can be viewed on the band and
labret swill about you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event you will now be redirected to
our upcoming cell culture heroes
webinars on November 21st at 9 a.m.
Pacific time the webinar is titled the
role of immune cells and immune
checkpoints in multiple myeloma
presented by Natalie honish PhD
candidate University Hospital Bonn
Germany we hope to see you there